en las imágenes podemos observar la
gobernación de chimborazo capital
riobamba misma que se encuentra tomada
por los indígenas ya desde hace tres
días punto de concentración de las
diferentes marchas es del panorama que
pudimos captar alrededor de las diez y
media desde ahí se encuentran las
diferentes organizaciones y líderes de
una asamblea permanente tomando
decisiones y medidas a tomar en esta
paralización que hoy cumple su séptimo
día alrededor de unas 60 personas
duermen en el interior a pesar de estar
en un estado de excepción y haber un
'toque de queda' que nadie puede
transitar por los edificios públicos de
20 horas a 5 horas de la mañana las
calles de parque de luces negras por la
quema de neumáticos los víveres van
escaseando y no se avisora ninguna terna
el gobierno por su parte no da el brazo
a torcer y los indígenas y las fuerzas
vivas de igual manera hasta que no se
derogue el decreto 883 que
principalmente subieron los combustibles
y por ende la canasta familiar